the Joe Rogan experience so imagine that
I came down from Mars and I look at you
know human civilization I think you know
this makes sense this makes sense this
makes sense this one doesn't make any
sense
well I was gonna use fights as an
example yeah what about the Colosseum I
mean it's always been a part of humans
right we've been interested in people
beating the [ __ ] out of each other since
the beginning of time yeah because it
scares us
so it's entertaining to watch other
people do it that's why we want to watch
a bar fight I don't want to be in a bar
fight you know a lot I'm gonna want to
be in a bar fight right but like what
the [ __ ] is really happening
so a lot of the people who have turned
against football the last let's say five
or ten years fueled by the CTE which is
obviously a legitimate thing we don't
really know the magnitude in the scope
yet but a lot of people who've turned
against it do it for a kind of moral
argument that I don't want to support an
endeavor where people are hurting each
other period right how do you feel about
that I mean should there's a libertarian
argument to say what are you talking
about people can do whatever they want
they can do drugs they can go bungee
jumping they can work stock trading
which is stressful you know can you can
do whatever you want so where do you lie
on that well I think first of all
they're right and you are doing
something that's definitely gonna harm
you however I feel like if you want to
do something that you enjoy doing that's
going to take some time out of your life
that's finite anyway who the [ __ ] am I
to tell you you can't do that right am I
gonna tell where am I gonna draw the
line am I gonna say no gymnastics yeah
like we're going to draw the line you
know do you know soccer causes
tremendous amount of CTE do you know
that yeah
what's causing the ball crosses sub
concussive trauma yeah just heading the
ball causes a lot of scene I know a lot
of youth leagues now are starting to cut
out head yeah I think it's probably a
pretty good it's a very good you should
probably eliminate it totally often it's
not the ball it's the collision with
you're dying often yeah yeah but they
think heading has a huge in no note what
I'm saying when you're going up for
headers you're often you're knocking
heads you're not gonna shoulder into a
head and elbow and they're running
around on a field and do a clip you're
gonna collide with each other where do
you stand on paying for organs but but
let's keep going with this because we
didn't even touch the surface of this
I'm in favor of people doing what they
want to do with their life if you choose
to do something with you life away are
we gonna take away race car driving
because that's one of the scariest
goddamn things a person can do not as
much anymore
music no yeah but you know what this is
I think [ __ ] up do you see that recent
crash I did but the fact that we
remember that so well one reason is
because there have been so few since
Earnhardt died back in whatever that was
mm listen I had Dale Earnhardt jr. on
this podcast and he want in depth about
brain damage that he's gotten from
multiple crashes he talked about the
severe impact of the concussions he
talked about the difficulty coming back
and the different modalities the
different medical treatments that he's
had to have that's Dale Earnhardt jr.
this is after his dad is gone right this
guy talked like really extensively on
this podcast about his personal struggle
with brain damage that he's received
from car accidents yeah it's a [ __ ]
scary way to make a living yeah arguably
more scary than fighting because there
are guys like Mighty Mouse
dimitra's Mighty Mouse Johnson who's
like this Elite MMA fighter that barely
gets touched there's guys like him that
don't take any damage and then there's
guys who are elite NASCAR drivers who
wind up these crazy collisions and go
sent through the air and they wind up in
the hospital all [ __ ] up the impact
just the impact even if you're in a cage
just your brain rattling around inside
your head [ __ ] you up and we're letting
people do that and I don't think we
should stop I think we should let people
do whatever they want if they want to do
they want to take a tightrope walk
across the Grand Canyon and film it on
YouTube I can't I'm not the guy unless
it's over private land or public land
with there's a law against using it who
are we to tell people they can't rock
climb who are we to tell people you
can't ski where do we draw the line yeah
where do you decide a person can't do a
thing I don't know you make a good
argument I don't think there's a bad
argument with what you're saying though
and saying that it's it Doug causes
damage to people you're right by the way
I'm a I love the NFL I would cry if it
went away on the other hand and I and I
know a few NFL will now former NFL
players one of whom stopped playing in
his fifth year way earlier than had to
because he was worried about CTE but
also he was getting a PhD in math
from MIT at the same time so he had a
plan
he had an alternative but then there's
another kinda combination he's in a MIT
you would you would you should have him
on your show John Herschel
his name is urs CHEO okay we'll talk
about a fascinating guy um there's
another guy Dominique Foxworth
both these guys happen to play for the
Ravens which happens to be the team I
hate most but I've got to be friendly
with them Dominique Ross worth had a
great money-making career because he
kind of got his big contract and is
whatever fourth fifth year well took out
insurance on it then got hurt and then
really never played again so he banked
enough money after that he went and got
an MBA from Harvard because he's a
bright and interesting and ambitious guy
he will never let his son play football
it's like you hear these stories about
the guys who've done it who've made a
life you know out of it and it just
really makes me think about you're right
everybody should have the right to do
anything for their own livelihood or for
their own excitement right on the other
hand like if we had the Coliseum today
per se like what we have is a modern
version the Coliseum if we had the
Coliseum per se fighting the tiger
slaves getting thrown in to fight the
Tigers we don't like that it's like the
line things are repugnant until they're
not and it's hard to predict where that
line is a lot of things that used to be
not repugnant slavery fine the whole
world if you had the ability to do it
right and then get go straight back to
the Coliseum it's the same thing it's
like we have a line and whatever the
cultural line is especially depending
upon how many people die around us how
much plague and murder and how much you
know how much you're dealing with war
that line moves yeah yeah
[Applause]